es ist eine Geschichte die im Moment
viele Städte und Gemeinden beschäftigt
es geht um Hilfsbereitschaft aber auch
um deren Grenzen denn es gibt so viele
Flüchtlinge wie noch nie in der
Bundesrepublik die Kleinstadt Gernsbach
in Baden-Württemberg ihr
SPD-Bürgermeister und sein
verständnisloser Blick auf die
Bundesregierung
ich halte die Flüchtlingspolitik für
verfehlt sie ist nicht nachhaltig sie
zeigt keine Perspektive auf Veränderung
oder Einsicht dieser sehr sehr
angespannten Situationen vor Ort und das
darf so nicht weitergehen
[Musik]
ein altes schon lange geschlossenes
Hotel soll Flüchtlingsunterkunft werden
gekauft von der Stadt Gernsbach wartet
auf Geld vom Bund auf mehr Unterstützung
der Bürgermeister hat Sorge dass die
Stimmung kippen könnte
meine Befürchtung ist dass am Ende des
Tages die extremen sein ist
Rechtsextremisten sein ist
Rechtspopulisten von dieser
flüchtlingskrise in der wir uns aktuell
befinden
profitieren werden es ist ein Hilferuf
gelebter Realität befindet sich Berlin
in einer anderen über eine Million
Flüchtlinge allein aus der Ukraine und
auch aus anderen Ländern haben sich die
Zahlen seit Jahresbeginn fast verdoppelt
Höchstgrenzen will die
bundesinnenministerin aber dennoch nicht
definieren das geht um die Frage auf der
einen Seite der Menschlichkeit die
Menschen kommen nicht einfach so hierher
sie kommen hierher weil sie ein Leib und
Leben bedroht sind und ich finde man
sollte sich dieser Tage warum erfahren
was würde man denn mit der eigenen
Familie machen wenn Krieg wäre würde man
da nicht auch das Land verlassen Frau
Ministerin
Braut dort gerade ein toxischen Cocktail
zusammen das Verweigern von Geldern an
die Kommunen die offenen Grenzen und die
Anreize die diese reg gesetzt an die
Menschen hier nach Europa zu kommen das
wird nicht mehr lange gut gehen keine
Obergrenze das gab es schon einmal 2015
Merkel die flüchtlingskrise Gesellschaft
und Politik bis zum Äußersten gespannt
gerade auch wegen dieses Satzes wir
haben so vieles geschafft wir schaffen
das eine politische Erklärung über das
Wie liefert die sie nicht dabei gab es
warnende Stimmen unser Herz ist weit
aber unsere Möglichkeiten sind endlich
2015 und heute wie sich die Bilder
ähneln Länder und Kommunen fürchten das
zusätzlich zu den aus der Ukraine
geflüchteten über 300.000 Menschen in
diesem Jahr in Deutschland Asyl
beantragen könnten wir Schlafwandeln in
eine neue europäische migrationskrise
hinein und deswegen brauchen wir jetzt
schnell Handlungsfähigkeit und schnell
antworten erstens ein Abkommen mit
Tunesien damit wir die Zahlen wieder
stabilisieren in den Griff kriegen und
zum zweiten muss die Kommission
Rückführungsabkommen verhandeln das
heißt abgelehnte also Bewerber müssen
Europa wieder verlassen Europa
debattiert über eine gemeinsame
Migrationspolitik Fluchtursachen
bekämpfen Kontrolle an den Außengrenzen
eine gemeinsame europäische Absicht
verliert sich in nationalen
Einzelinteressen wieder einmal
hierzulande wächst der Druck auf die
Innenministerin Gemeinden Städte und
Länder über alle Parteigrenzen hinweg
Protest gegen ihre Flüchtlingspolitik
das Thema müsse endlich auch im
Kanzleramt ankommen Chefsache werden die
flüchtlingskrise so groß wie noch nie
nicht mehr warten können das gilt auch
für die Kleinstadt Gernsbach sie will es
gut machen doch die aktuelle Politik
oder nicht Politik in Berlin treibt sie
in die Überforderung wie viele andere
Kommunen auch